aux douanes à Bondy durant la
même période.
- L'aéroport international
Montréal-Trudeau reprend
lentement vie,
mais ses activités
sont encore au ralenti.
Ce qui n'a pas ralenti au cours
de la dernière année toutefois,
ce sont les saisies réalisées
aux douanes. Au Canada, entre
avril 2020 et avril 2021,
le nombre de saisies, toutes
marchandises confondues, est
passé de 51 000 à 75 000,
une hausse de 50 %.
Les quantités de fentanyl
et autres opioïdes saisies
ont augmenté, tout comme
celles des produits illégaux
du cannabis et d'armes
prohibées.
MARIE-ÈVE LETELLIER, conseillère
stratège., Agence services Can.
- C'est simple, c'est pas
parce que le nombre de voyageurs
a diminué que nous, on a arrêté
de travailler. Les criminels
et les contrebandiers, c'est pas
une pandémie qui va les arrêter.
Y'ont un "marché" à faire rouler
donc, ça a continué.
- Si le nombre de voyageurs
qui arrivent au Canada a chuté
de plus de 90 % dans
cette année de pandémie,
les agents des services
frontaliers ne se sont pas
tourné les pouces pour autant.
Presque chaque jour, l'équipe
de Marie-Ève Letellier effectue
des saisies.
- Là, on se dirige vers la zone
d'inspection secondaire. On a
trouvé de la méthamphétamine,
on a trouvé des quantités
de cocaïne, d'héroïne,
ça, ça continue toujours.
Qu'on parle de drogues,
de devises, d'objets de luxe,
c'est la nature humaine.
Donc, pandémie pas pandémie,
des gens qui veulent essayer
dese faufiler dans le système,
il va toujours y en avoir.
- Maxime Sauriol
et son compagnon de travail
Gonzo, spécialiste
de la détection des produits
alimentaires et agricoles,
ont remarqué un phénomène
nouveau ces derniers mois.
MAXIME SAURIOL, maître-chien,
Agence services frontaliers Can
- Étonnamment, on a vu beaucoup
de passagers apporter
de la nourriture pour
la quarantaine, donc pour faire
l'isolement à la maison,
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne
voyait pas avant, évidemment.
Donc, des passagers qui veulent
être préparés pour faire
la quarantaine, par ce que
les gens apportaient des
aliments sans nécessairement
savoir si c'était admissible
ou non. Donc Gonzo a été bien
occupé avec eux.
- Mais ce qui explique surtout
la hausse des saisies,
c'est ce qui se passe
à l'extérieur de la zone
des voyageurs.
- Avec la pandémie, ce qu'on a
constaté, c'est que
les contrebandiers trouvaient
des façons différentes, disons,
d'importer des produits
au Canada. Donc on a vu
une explosion, si on peut ainsi
dire, au niveau
de la messagerie, le commerce
en ligne, il y a eu de plus en
plus, de colis qui ont été reçus
dans nos installations
et les contrebandiers en ont
profité pour glisser de plus
en plus de leur marchandise
à l'intérieur de ces mêmes
colis.
- Parmi les saisies notoires,
25 kilos d'opium et 6500 kilos
de masques N95 frauduleux.
- Oui, il y a des contrebandiers
au niveau cargo, mais s'il y a
une chose qu'on a faite de bien
pendant la pandémie par exemple,
au niveau de l'agence, faut
quand même le souligner qu'à
partir du mois de décembre,
on a quand même accueilli
25 millions de doses de vaccins.
Ce que la pandémie va nous avoir
apporté, c'est de nouvelles
techniques de travail,
des nouveaux outils de travail
aussi, dont l'application
ArriveCan.
- ArriveCan a vu le jour pendant
la pandémie pour accompagner
les voyageurs avant leur arrivée
au Canada et pendant
leur quarantaine.
- C'est sûrement appelé à rester
pour une période prolongée. Donc
nous, ici, ce qu'on fait très
bien, c'est qu'on s'adapte.
On va continuer à le faire,
c'est certain. Donc, quand
les restrictions vont être
levées, nous, on va être prêts
puis on va être prêts
à accueillir tout le monde.
- Et les douaniers ont bien
raison de se préparer, parce que
dès juillet, les Canadiens et
résidents permanents pleinement
vaccinés qui reviennent de
l'étranger pourront bénéficier
d'assouplissement. Promesse d'un
afflux de voyageurs renouvelé
à nos frontières.
Ici Fannie Bussières McNicoll,
Radio-Canada, Mo